it's nearly five weeks since rebecca
lucas submitted a visa application to
bring illona and her daughter marta to
westcliff on sea in essex and away from
the terror in their home town of turner
pill they they had to escape quickly so
they have to escape really quickly
elona's husband stanislav wrote a note
giving his consent for his daughter to
travel to the uk with his wife while he
stayed to fight
but still they wait i don't want to be
lied to i'm fed up of being lied to
um
i want i want the truth you know if my
doctor if you know if their documents
have been lost
i want to know that they've been lost
and how have they been lost their case
is far from unique in theory
applications are dealt with
chronologically but barrister amanda
jones isn't convinced she's taken on
nine judicial review cases of ukrainian
refugees experiencing similar weights
the initial form was extraordinarily
cumbersome and repetitive
and required a separate form for each
member of the family including babies
it's been streamlined quite a lot
although it's still
relatively complex
and it appears to me quite probable that
the home office is expediting the easy
later cases in order to
up the numbers that they can say
have been processed the latest figures
show 86 000 visas have been granted dina
koroshkos is one of them but only after
a second application was submitted and
approved in just six days she'll be
moving in with the bank's family and
western super mario there's hundreds if
not thousands of people in the same
position that we're in
who didn't put in that second
application like we did
and that continued to wait i think
dina is finally due to arrive in mid-may
the government says it's aware some
people have been waiting more than a
month to find out if their application
has been approved describing that as
unacceptable but they say that thousands
of visas are being processed every day
and work is being done to speed up the
system even further
for now marta and ilona must share a bed
in a bomb shelter
there's the safety of a home far from
the missiles in england but no one knows
when they'll finally get there
emma birchley sky news